a brawl turns deadly in laughlin one man
is dead after police say a big fight
erupted
at the aquarius hotel early this morning
victoria saha has the details from
loughlin
metro police and homicide detectives
spend majority of their day
inside the aquarius hotel trying to
piece together what happened
some of the guests i spoke with today
say some parts of the hotel
were blocked off to them this is video a
witness shared with us you can see
bystanders and what looks like security
attend to someone on the floor
after the fight police tell us the big
fight broke out
with up to 30 people early this morning
inside the hotel
they say when they got there there was a
victim unresponsive
this person was taken to the hospital
where he died some guests tell me they
were told to avoid the mcdonald's area
and there are still cones and
crime tape up this afternoon i guess he
got
beat up pretty bad like my three i don't
know it's like a whole bunch of people
they said
so they got i guess they jumped they
jumped them pretty much and they threw a
barstool at the guy
police have not said if they made any
arrests the witness also tells us he saw
a couple of other people being helped
out by paramedics but
police would not confirm that reporting
from laughlin victoria saha 8 news now